uh before we move on a reminder do check
out the sofa ridge on sunday podcast it
features the best bits of our interviews
each week plus analysis from me and my
producer matt aveda
it's available from lunchtime on the sky
news app spotify and
apple podcast so do check that out now
labour is today calling for the debt
built up by businesses during the
pandemic to be treated like
student debt now to talk about that and
more we're joined by the shadow
chief secretary bridget phillipson i'm
keen to talk about your business plan
but first if i may i'm keen to start on
schools we're just talking to anne
longfield there about the impact
on children that the pandemic has had
the government wants schools to return
from march the 8th does that need to be
all schools or would you be happy if
primary schools for example
or schools in some regions when i went
in first
well the government does need to be very
much guided by all of the science and
the data that's made available to them
but absolutely schools should be the
first to open which should be a real
priority for the government
to make sure that our children can get
back to school and all parents will have
seen the impact that being out of school
for many children or the disruption to
education
that's been caused particularly for the
most vulnerable children
you know the fact that children can't
play with their friends in the same way
anymore
you know the educational impact has been
severe but yes we do absolutely need to
see children all children back in school
as quickly as possible that just does
need to be done safely say that all
children should be back in school as
quickly as possible that it should be
done safely i mean that is exactly what
we'd hear from
dominic rob a few moments ago as well
should all schools
and all year groups go back at the same
time or would you be happy to see a
staggered approach
well the government does need to
consider the advice that they receive
and it may be necessary
to stagger that but we will work with
the government to make sure that it's
done in a careful considered way
but we do also need to see a much
clearer plan set out from the government
around supporting children to catch up
on the misleading that they've had to
experience
but also making sure as you heard just
earlier from the children's commissioner
that we look at all of the impacts on
children's well-being overall because
you know it has been a really difficult
time children have lost out such a great
deal
but we do need to make sure that when
they go back it's as safe as possible
so if the scientific advice is that it
would be safer to for example allow
younger children to
return first or to allow some new groups
like those taking exams to return first
you'd be happy with that we'll look at
what the government says but of course
we the government should be guided
by the data and the science it's
available and we look carefully at what
they set out it should be done
in a measured way i think parents and
teaching staff will understand it has to
be done
carefully and following the best
possible advice okay now we understand
that labour
wants to allow businesses who have built
up debt during the pandemic i'm sure a
lot of businesses that applies to
for that to be treated like student debt
just explain the idea to us
we know that so many businesses have had
a really really tough year i've heard
from so many of them
that they're really starting to find
that debt mountain they've built up hard
to deal with
and they need breathing space to get
through this crisis so we don't believe
that businesses should be paying back
money that they've needed to borrow
until they're in a much stronger
position and until they're growing again
we know that in this country we've had
the worst economic crisis of any major
economy
and as right now going into the next
months ahead
850 000 businesses are at risk and that
puts two and a half million jobs on the
line
we need to see urgent action from the
government now to deal with that they
can't wait
until the budget they need urgent action
from the chancellor
to help them get through this time some
businesses of course
may never be able to pay off the amount
of debt that they have built
up during this unbelievable year so
under your plan
could that debt be written off and
effectively covered by the taxpayer in
the same way
that it is with student loans
well it's more likely that that some of
that debt will be written off if we
don't take action now because
businesses many of them particularly
smaller businesses are just drowning
under this debt and they need to see
real concerted action from the
government
of course some businesses are in a
stronger position particularly some of
those
larger businesses and we take a
different approach there but you know
what we've been listening to business we
know that they'll be driving
the recovery that we need to see the
growth that we need to see in job
creation
so we need to be working with them to
make sure that the solutions that we put
in place
don't see good businesses going bust
because of short-term decision-making
so it could it could be written off as
the answer
well unless we take action debt will be
written off that's that's for sure
so putting in place a plan that allows
businesses to deal with this in a formal
manageable way
would be a responsible way to be
approaching this businesses just don't
understand why the chancellor hasn't got
to grips
with the crisis that they're facing he
isn't listening we also need to see i
believe
a smart furlough introduced to support
businesses to get through this
we also believe that the extension of
the business rates holiday should
continue
but also to see that further extension
of the vat cut
you know so many businesses have found
this a real struggle over the course of
the last year
and if they go bust it will make our
recovery so much harder
okay of course all these plans will
cost money or take money as well we've
seen the worst fall in gdp since the
invention
of gdp this week and many would like to
see the chancellor start to
rebalance the books if you like when he
has
gives the budget in march now kirsten
said this week that over the course of
the recovery
tax rises are not the right way to go
so are there any tax risers that rishi
cena could propose in the budget that
you would support
you'll struggle to find an economic
expert who believes that right now we
should be raising taxes
on families whereas in fact the
chancellor is doing precisely that
with his council tax hit if we pressed
ahead with tax rises now that would pull
demand
out of our economy it would mean that
families have got less money to spend
in our shops and high streets and it
would damage the recovery that i think
we all want to see
you know we are at a fork in the road
now we want to see britain come back
strongly and to emerge from this
terrible terrible pandemic that we've
experienced
but if the chancellor presses ahead with
tax rises not only will it hurt families
but it will be economically illiterate
and as i say you'd struggle to find
anybody right now
who's saying that tax rises on families
the right way to be going about this
i'm not talking about tax prices on
families specifically are there any tax
risers that rishi sunet could propose
that labour would support
now absolutely isn't the time to
pressing ahead with tax tax rises that
is an approach that we would support
okay thank you now i just want to talk
to you a little bit about
labor 116 000 people have now died after
testing positive for covid we've seen
the biggest economic hit since the great
frost in 1709
and yet the conservatives have actually
managed to extend
the poll lead over labour their leading
labour in the polls
lots of people will be looking at that
thinking why isn't labour doing better
in the circumstances
well a little over a year ago we
suffered one of the worst general
election defeats
in our history so we always knew that it
was going to take a long time
to regain the trust of the british
people once more but i think we've made
tremendous progress over the course
of that time under kia stammers new
leadership if you'd said to me
in december 2019 that we would have made
the progress we've made
already i would have taken off your
right arm to have been
making such fantastic progress but of
course you know after such a terrible
defeat it will take time
to regain the trust of the british
people once more we've always been clear
about that
um but at the same time i think there is
an expectation from the british people
that we're constructive in the
opposition that we put to the government
this is a crisis like no other so we
have pushed the government and given
voice to the concerns that we've had not
least on the economic recovery
where because we've had the worst
economic crisis of any major economy
we face a very difficult path back and
that's because going into this crisis
the country was built on weak economic
foundations but you know we're making
great progress of course
of course it's a party there is more to
do okay and some on the left of the
party are getting
a little bit jittery uh people like john
mcdonnell at the unite
union wanting to see a june emergency
conference to try and address some of
their concerns
now those in the left i guess would like
you to take a few more risks to call for
things that aren't just going to happen
anyway to differentiate
between labor and the government is the
problem that labour at the minute is
just a bit boring
well you know we're years out for an
election so of course we'll set out very
detailed
policy that rises to the challenge that
britain faces at that point
but we are in the middle of a pandemic
after all and we absolutely have to be
focused
on getting the country through this
crisis but we have made tremendous
progress as a party but you know when i
think back to that terrible election
defeat
uh in december 2019 the first priority
for us as a party had to be
earning the right to be heard once more
by the british people we've done that i
think kia stammer has demonstrated
that he is a prime minister next prime
minister for this country he's ready to
do that job
and there is genuine and real enthusiasm
from people that i speak to about the
progress that labour
has made of course there is still much
more that we need to do we always knew
it would be a tough road ahead
okay thank you for coming on the show it
looks very picturesque and snowy where
you are but
bit chilly as well so i hope you've got
a nice cup of tea somewhere standing by
and thank you for being on thank you